you like you like jail
I'm not gonna say I like jail I just
think it was an experience that saved my
life
like I mean you know if he's probably
like a white kid grew up in the suburbs
I'm just [ __ ] your mom sent you to
summer camp yeah I never went through
that I'm from the hood I'm from Detroit
you know are you saying jail is a black
summer camp
oh dude I went there and it made me
discover who I was kind of because I'm
you alone
and you know I've always had family you
got friends gangs or whatever [ __ ]
you know you always feel protected in
the hood yeah you know you got some
status for yourself or whatever
everybody gonna look out for you but
when I went to jail all that [ __ ] erased
how long are you in jail I only did a
year I was in a comedy which is even
worse yeah yeah yeah if I would have got
if you got fed it's a little bit easier
but I did the most you could possibly
doing the county I did a year and then
um which is eight months but I kept
getting caught smoking cigarettes and
doing [ __ ] so I was getting extra time
like I think I did like too much extra
time of what I was supposed to do it was
like damn you having this much fun in
this [ __ ]
exactly but I will say you meet the
funniest [ __ ] in the world are
in jail why like you're literally saying
stand-up sets every day really like okay
you guys just got to entertain one
another there's nothing else going on
time to write it's that whole thing and
I um
I think before I went to jail I was kind
of like more shy I probably didn't talk
a lot like how I am now like I'm funny
to everybody you know that kind of [ __ ]
I could just get into a room and just
start talking and be like I never was
like that before that and I went there
and I was by myself I couldn't I didn't
have nobody I could so you got it you
don't talk you go [ __ ] gonna punk you
it's gonna be some [ __ ] I did it happen
anybody try you
see it was see I'm I'm an ill [ __ ] what
happened
I swear to God what happened was when I
first got to jail I was like normal
everybody else I worked in the kitchen
yeah and you know washing dishes and
[ __ ] we call that they call that water
world because you're about to be wet as
[ __ ] no matter what you do it sounds fun
kind of yeah the world was terrible if I
worked in the water world but I had it
really is summer camp so I was working
in water on the slip and slide so I'm
working in Water World and [ __ ] but
that's right and you know on my rock
that's what they call your premium my
rock it was you know you got a rock boss
and my rock boss worked in registry okay
and registry is literally the best job
you can get in jail because Registries
when all the inmates come in and they
get registered so whatever inmate has on
them you know they just throw it in the
garbage and you working at registry
you're the one that got to take the
garbage out so garbage you're getting
all the cigarettes all the weed all the
whatever so you get what I'm saying so
you're the guy so really the person the
people that work at registry is the one
that pulled the supply to jail
cigarettes you're taking all the jail
from registry then you selling them to
other rocks and [ __ ] like that is are
you supposed to sorry to interrupt this
but like when you go to jail are you
supposed to bring like a pack of
cigarettes that you know is going to be
taken but that's your kind of gift no I
wouldn't I mean running man
can we stop at the Chevron I gotta pick
up a survival pack on me and my balls
you're going to like a baby shower or
something
bro I'm just saying you're going in you
know what I mean you got to spread booty
hole when you come in that [ __ ]
that's part of registry too I just had
to do it every day what bro cause when
you work in Water World they expect you
know a [ __ ] gonna steal some food or
something you're gonna sneak something
back up to the Rock
so when you get back up to the Rock the
CEO of that Rocky like nuts and bolts
nuts and bolts that means get butt naked
spread that booty hoe but you know me I
was still sneaking [ __ ] up but in your
booty don't no I will um I would sneak
cigarettes up I would cut you see how
your t-shirts
why are you like fisting I was gonna say
bro
so my rock balls
they would sit in their [ __ ] dorm
room him and his friends and they would
be rapping
and it's the most terrible rapping you
can possibly hear and you know me I I
really does this [ __ ] but I don't pale
people it's not like I'm gonna be like I
got bars I got bars I don't do that yeah
that's embarrassing kind of so I always
shut up and I maybe probably went
through it for like months and months of
just hearing these [ __ ] on a Saturday
when we on our off day yeah and they're
in their room just doing terrible rap
and rap into each other so I just think
one day I just got fed up okay and I
just kicked in a doe like [ __ ] bro
we're gonna show you how this [ __ ]
really done and I started rapping for
the [ __ ] and just kick them spicy meal
[ __ ] because I was writing in jail all
the time too so I just kicked the price
of ill [ __ ] this nigga's like he just
got enamored by me and I became like the
the right hand man to the Rock boss on
the Rock so he like [ __ ] when I leave
when I leave
um when I get uh when I get out of here
I'm gonna give you my registry job wow
oh so you got hooked up so I left Water
World and he put me in registry now the
thing about registry is like I said this
is all the new animates coming in so
let's just say you know Court days
you're you're the guy responsible for
passing out sandwiches to [ __ ] so
every day you about to get into it with
a [ __ ] over the sandwiches or I might
see a [ __ ] cause these [ __ ] are
saying [ __ ] oh you police ass [ __ ]
working with these police
you got to think all these [ __ ] going
to court they're either about to go home
are they about to go to the penitentiary
or rather be in the county so
everybody's on the edge yeah you got to
go in the sale clean up after these
[ __ ] and do [ __ ] like that you know
what I'm saying so what I would do is
this is how I avoided beef I will um
find the biggest inmate I can possibly
see be like how much time you got in
this pitch anybody he'd be like Oh I'm
about to get out or I'm gonna go to
Penitentiary [ __ ] but I'm about to be
here by six months oh you're coming down
working with me so you get the biggest
biggest [ __ ] so when I'm passing those
um sandwiches and [ __ ] I got to say yeah
because I had long french braids and
[ __ ] I'm not really tall and skinny so
everybody called me snooping Geo and I
remember one time he pulled me to the
side he's like you know he's like he
figured out how finessed them for
protection yeah like Snoop you wouldn't
go through a lot of this [ __ ] if he
wasn't so self-centered you need to have
a little more empathy for people
who is this they got self-aware
[ __ ] go to therapy go to therapy
can Dr Phil in jail
yeah there's one place to be so sad yes
it's a [ __ ] what is you talking
about right now we surviving man you're
like yeah Snoop you you just need to
have a little more empathy oh [ __ ] for
inmates
that's not baloney sandwiches
got me [ __ ] up oh so to say that again
I was the [ __ ] in charge of all the
cigarettes yeah so for the entire time
that I was in jail nobody got cigarettes
smoke them all
selling cigarette
you know what I'm saying I like bro I
was so ill it was one point in time I
was just so plugged into the jail yeah
you're crazy
[ __ ] in the county jail man
this cartel sells the drugs I would I
need some cigarettes you gonna braid my
hair
you're a tyrant I've had the freshest
braids in jail because you picked the
dude to do it I didn't know he it was
awesome it was just one guy I mean they
want the cigarettes but he was like
because when you get your hair
between his legs
[Laughter]
I forgot about it
so this is what I like to do too so
being that I work registry not only do I
have the service or the male inmates I
got to start the female inmates oh so
you actually got to go over there
good save the what I would get the court
slips well you can see what they going
through and this and that and now I see
a [ __ ] I know her number I'm like oh
that's Courtney Johnson inmate number
five oh and I just write the [ __ ] a
note
Senator you know I'm the one that worked
registry I always gave you the sandwich
the other day you're a bad [ __ ] well
you know we both
we both are here going through it you
know what I'm saying we can help our
time go a little bit easier with
communication you know what I'm saying
so I see you when you come down for work
I'll throw you an extra little something
I got cigarettes too you know cigarettes
you know what I'm saying you were
listening to two shots
for the women why not let them braid
your hair no I can't I can't you can't
go on that oh all we had was a window we
have a window if you was on a certain
floor which was the best rock to be on
you could look out the window and then
you can see the bitch's floor too and
we'll be in the window jacking off and
[ __ ]
my homies
got caught jacking in the window he got
sent back to greens because you know
when you work registry that's when you
were oranges you know they put you in
Orange uniform and being in Orange you
got a little more leniency that you
getting more food you're getting just a
better way of living in County Jail
being in Greens is like Lily Gladiator
school like you sleeping there like 12
man bunk tears [ __ ] like that you know
what I'm saying bro I was in Greens one
day man that [ __ ] was bro that [ __ ] was
the scariest [ __ ] in my life soon as the
[ __ ] soon as it went dark it's
like lights out you just seen everybody
it was like squid game bro
I can't wait to get the oranges man
[Laughter]
I was writing all the [ __ ] in there
one of my [ __ ] got eight years man I
wrote her through her whole [ __ ]
Court time man what did she do she
stabbed the [ __ ] over her boyfriend the
[ __ ] showed up her boyfriend was
[ __ ] another [ __ ] something the
[ __ ] showed up on some fighting [ __ ]
and she just trying to protect herself
stabbed the [ __ ] they gave her
manslaughter she got eight years for
that [ __ ] did you guys ever hook up it
was just notes just notes did you pick
them based off their crimes how they
look
really yeah you got to think man drug
dealer [ __ ] got bad [ __ ] they it's a
lot of [ __ ] you know that'd be some
you'll see some crazy [ __ ] in jail like
damn [ __ ] what you doing in here yeah
what you doing in here so Alex is in his
previous life used to put black people
in jail
I was a court officer I just made sure
you guys sit down and keep you take your
hat off while using it
you're the fans bro
all right so at what point do you start
going back to women braiding your hair
or do you always stay with God there's
this part so I was it was just a time
you know you look dirty in jail your
braids is all [ __ ] up and [ __ ] and it
was like just I put the word I was
looking for a hair braider and then um
one of the guys he was like oh I his
whole story was that
um his mom worked crazy hours at work
and then he he was just had all little
sisters he was the older brother yeah I
heard that one so he used to have to
back yeah I had to take care of my
sisters
whatever yes right I ever since all
types
part two I was wearing Rick Owens every
day like come on bro Rick on inmate this
is how that's how I was so into
fashioned still in jail so I got so I
got cool I got cool with a [ __ ] that
worked in laundry and I would make him
give me the biggest shirts you can find
in the smallest pants you can find so my
inmate outfits look different anyway and
then I was able to get my Air Max 97s
out of property I paid so I'm the only
[ __ ] wearing Air Max 97 I thought it
was 95 since you like no 95 is my
favorite yeah but I had 97s when I got
locked up that's why I never wear them
again I'd never buy a pair of 97s again
because they remind you of getting your
hair braided by a guy yeah
I don't think I'm gonna go to jail man
and I love Air Max 97s man but I could
never wear them again because it just
reminded me of being in jail yeah yeah
yeah all silver with the red Knight yeah
it seems like jail wasn't that bad for
you though yeah
at this it's summer camp yeah but why
don't this is like a show this is a TV
show all the time it's a comedy oh that
would be a funniest ass show hell yeah
oh part oh man I was making these [ __ ]
watch America's top model these things
be mad like man put the Piston game on
no we watch America
[Laughter]
so I can always just give you a
cigarette to shut the [ __ ] up
um I'm in my my bunk I've got 30 packs
where are the cigarettes I'm just hiding
my room so every time I got raided I
would get caught that's how I get an
extra time
she kept your job as registry even
though yeah because I was Snoop and they
were scared to get another inmate they
were already comfortable with me at that
point the CEOs were yeah yeah
part two days always tell me like you
not an inmate like I don't know what
happened in your life but yeah you this
is not for you and I hope I never I hope
you never come back I hope I never
because most people you know they always
say you gonna come back but you they
didn't want to die next time they saw me
I was on magazine covers and [ __ ] hit me
up on Twitter Instagrams yeah like man
Snoop you did it you I can't believe you
I can't believe you did this [ __ ] and it
was yeah it was great but see even when
I was getting my hair braided I was
doing like they would swap me out for
another inmate on another rock because
the inmate that was braiding in here he
was the best hair braider he wasn't on
my rock so I was that cool with the CEO
they would take another just wake you up
like [ __ ] look about to come get his
hair braided go over here
you don't even know for a couple hours
while I'm over there getting my [ __ ]
braided get the [ __ ] out of here